joining me now is a republican who
democrats have in their crosshairs
colorado congresswoman
lauren bobert congressman congresswoman
bobert you were singled out by the head
of the democrat
congressional campaign committee as
being next
your response tonight i have been on
their list
since the day i announced uh this
certainly isn't a surprise to me it's
kind of a game of whack-a-mole at this
point
so you kind of you kind of knock one
down and three more pop
up but i'm encouraged because i know
that the d triple c
is terrified of what this freshman class
is doing
where the republican party is going and
the momentum that is still behind us
in 74 million million americans
and i am proud to be a part of this i am
honored to be the first
woman to represent the people of
colorado's third district the first
mom that has been sent to washington dc
to be
their voice and so the d triple c can
throw whatever they want at me
it's not going to stick i'll keep
whacking down the moles and
you're exactly right uh we can't just
keep sacrificing
republicans to the d-triple c into the
democrat party
they will look after their their next
head
i just want to make this very clear to
everyone watching now
we have to translate washington to the
rest of the country every night
with all due respect it's not about you
it's not about congresswoman greene
it's not it's not about any one of you
this is about
trying to take out anyone ever connected
to donald trump because they don't want
to have to spend that much money again
to meet someone like him in 2024
that means take out anyone connected
with him they said it's a third of the
republican party or third of the country
still supports his ideas
it's about the ideas congresswoman
that's what they want to brand as
ray sister white supremacist even though
they were quite popular
among uh various minority groups
laura you are absolutely right this is a
movement that the democrats can't seem
to stop
they have spent millions of dollars
trying to do that and
in all of this they only expose their
hypocrisy
and show that they're never going to
hold one another accountable
they're they're never going to uh to
stand on their own and be accountable
for their own decisions
really the democrat party is is a party
of cancel culture that's a pillar
of the democrat party when you have
alexandria ocasio-cortez
accusing senator cruz of nearly
murdering her or comparing
congressman chip roy's actions to a
sexual abuser
this is ridiculous and someone at some
time needs to hold them accountable
and maybe it's the freshman class
the media love to trot out former
congressmen you know who don't have to
actually answer to constituents anymore
like the never trumper charlie dent and
he thinks he has a way of
saving the gop watch
the party needs to make a clean break
from trump and i would argue a clean
break from trumpism uh with all of its
uh ugly uh populism isolationism
protectionism we need to empower adam
kinzinger
and those who want a new direction for
the party that is much more socially
tolerant constructively engaged
on the international and domestic stage
oh my god my hair hurts congresswoman is
this what the party needs
republicans that's not the fight that i
was sent here to be a part of
and so my agenda is taking back the
house in in 2022 and representing the
people
of colorado but i don't see the
republican party going away from this
america first agenda
laura that's what motivated me to get to
washington d.c
i have four children i know that
conservative values
are are what leads them to a free and
prosperous life
they are terrified of me and people like
me i grew up in a democrat home
dependent on democrat policies and those
policies failed me
they led me to stand in line for
government cheese well
because the american dream is still
available now i'm in washington dc
fighting to make sure no one else ever
has to do that well they're they're
they're afraid of you you're optimistic
you're young you're
new and they want to scare you if it
sounds like they're not doing a very
good job of it congresswoman thank you
so much great thank you so much laura